[Music]
Levi pointed out some pretty gaping
holes in your system
want you to meet our new stringer won't
you show him the ropes this is Clark
Kent
what is his place oh my god look at this
you clown
I come from did i adequately answer your
condescending question
it's not it is on my world in me talk no
there's no there's no hope I'll
surrender wow you would do that for me
my colleagues and I are doing things
that no one in this room are
intellectually or creatively capable of
doing huh my dad is dead
[ __ ] he didn't have to be that rough on
him
let me warn you I want you to follow I
guess no matter what you think you might
know we will always be one step three
steps seven steps ahead of you and at no
time will you be anywhere other than
exactly where I want you to be so come
close get get all over me because the
closer you think you are the less you'll
actually see first rule of magic always
be the smartest guy in the room
when I am alone at night when I am
jerking off uh I am thinking of you
while we're making the sweetest love we
can possibly make without dying I know
what we have to do we've all got to have
sex together I'm still holding out hope
that justice Lee could be good but it
does seem a little bit like oh we got to
catch up we gotta catch up meet us you
know oh my god they're making another
good movie they're making a good movie
they're making a movie
I bet a [ __ ] raccoon and we can't
even do Wonder Woman